تعدد القوات الحامله للسلاح داخل ايران
التلك الرسميه وتلك الموازيه هذا يثير همم
السؤال اذا ما كان بالامكان تصور مثلا نوع
من انواع الاحتجاج او التمرد داخل القوات
الحامله للسلاح مع
تصاعد الانتفاضه اكثر من ما هو حاصل الان
او يوما بيوم على الارض في ايران
على الاطاحها بالانظامه الحرس الثوري وفي
اللحظه التي لا يؤمنون فيها بيانات الله
عليه خامنها يخدموا المصالح المؤسسيه اللي
حرس الثوري فلانيه تردد ولا للحظه للتضحيه
به ما هو تاثير خلافه المرشد الاعلى على
الوضع العام في ايران لانه في حديث عنها
الان
قال لي الخلافه علي الخامنئي قد لا تكون
على نفس قدري اهميه سلطه لحرس الثوري لان
لا قائده ايران يمكن ان يخلف على خامنئي
في السلطه ما لم يحصل على مباركه الحرس
الثوري واذا كان هنالك من القاده دينيين
يصبح خليفه
ايضا سيكون خادم لحرس الثوري بكلمات اخرى
الاسلاميه ستصبح منظومه برئيس الدوله رجل
الدين وواجهه مدنيه ولكنها في الواقع
الحارس الثوري هو الذي يتخذ والقرارات
الاستراتيجيه في النظام السياسيه كما
يوزعوا ثروات ايران كما يشاء